you were not playing with the children
tonight
joey king just given it to him jealous i
see people with their martinis on that
side i know right you look over there
you're like damn it so overwhelming
look at oh no no no but you you brought
it tonight the look you were going for
what i mean it is so chic and gorgeous
yeah i felt like uh like there's part of
it that gives flapper and then there's
also like i wanted to give a futuristic
vibe i was really really going for
futuristic now i did see a little smooch
at the top of the red carpet
i mean your fellas it's a good looking
fella isn't he
i know i am like i know i tell the whole
night i've just been like ah
when i saw him like they make a dashing
couple like seriously you dressed up him
put together i was like okay thank you
so much all right so big night tonight
we've been waiting so long for this
movie joey i know you guys probably have
been too so how are you feeling about
shutting down you know the west side of
la i mean this is so amazing this red
carpet is so beautiful and elaborate
this it's just it's just like the movie
our movie is so much fun and this carpet
reflects that this night reflects that
i'm having such a good time already
right so your last project was the
princess right you played the princess
and now you're playing
prince
prince i was the princess and i'm the
prince and i'm the king i don't know are
we trying to keep this royalty train
going and when you hear that you're like
okay
okay such a funny coincidence because i
did film them quite far apart but then
they came out back to back and so it was
just like a really funny like weird
coincidence what i think i've loved so
much about seeing you guys so far on
this press tour is the fact you really
look like you love each other having fun
dancing hugging hanging what is it about
the chemistry of this cast hey you know
i don't know we just all get along so
well like it's just really really good
fun i mean first of all we've got brad
who you know just kind of sets the tone
i mean he's an amazing talented leader
of our band we like to call ourselves a
band the band all right we have a whole
band name and everything but okay what
is it it's called we're called naked
below the line that's our band name
do i want to know the story behind that
yes i don't even remember the story
behind it it was just i don't know how
it happened but that's us but we just i
don't know we just have just the most
wonderful friendship and i'm so grateful
for it because you know there's nothing
better than loving a project you're
doing and then also being proud of the
outcome of what you guys did together
yeah and you were you mentioned brad of
course arguably one of the biggest stars
in the world i mean movie star with
capital m and s exactly you know so what
was it like working with him and was it
sometimes do you kind of get lost in
just kind of watching him work i mean
he's so amazingly normal and it's so
wonderful because i was overwhelmed and
a little intimidated when i first came
on to this project because it's just
like
holy cannoli an action film with david
leitch and brad pitt like this is wild
um and you get on that set and it just
feels so comfortable and like exciting
and you know you can take risks and and
brad is such a big cheerleader for
everybody it's just really it was wild
to be like wow what a what a nice
freaking normal guy
[Music]